i've never really done anything like
this it was quite
exciting from weight lifting to workouts
that go on for hours to very unusual and
painful muscle making methods these
marvel stars have done it all which
actors found strength they never knew
they had and who was left hurting let's
see this is knowledge knowledge is power
no it's not knowledge is not power
that's power
another day another body transformation
he's sick and he's frail and he's really
dying before eyes so that was
incredibly challenging transforming his
body for a role is something jared leto
seems to have perfected by this point
and he did not shy away from bulking up
to play morbius not only did he commit
to getting ripped for the role he also
committed to a very uncomfortable and
unnatural way of moving for parts of the
movie contorting his body to the point
that co-stars like adria orhona became
worried i remember fearing for this
guy's spine there should have been a
therapist on call between cardio
weightlifting and yoga leto has got
physical transformations on lock
number two
welcome to the mcu oscar he knew what
was expected of him as a marvel actor
and he did not hesitate in getting
straight to work gaining muscle mass and
toning up mainly through weapons
training and martial arts since he did
most of his own stunts in moon night a
lot of practical training had to happen
and to top it all off isaac was even
doing boxing and gymnastics just to make
sure his training covered everything he
was very well set up by the time filming
began ready to whip out those marvel
stunts take after take
number
hello doctor strange this is benedict
cumberbatch like we have never seen him
before the multiverse of madness film
has had him hitting the gym hard with a
huge emphasis on weightlifting
explaining why he's looking so buff but
the actor the physical transformation
was actually a great part of the
experience overall explaining i like
that kind of element of acting i like
transformative stuff rounding out that
training with a healthy balanced diet
and frequent yoga well you've got a
recipe for a very muscular doctor
strange
number four
spider-man just doing whatever a spider
can and this spider can bulk up tom
holland seems to have to work out most
of the time for his movie roles but his
training for no way home well it wasn't
the most fun he's ever had it's awful
it's a lot of fun and it works but it
really is the worst thing i've ever done
the actor did all the usual work hit
training body weight workouts cardio
weight training boxing
but he also did some ems training which
is what exactly it's like you wear this
sort of like black suit and they put
these pads on you and you basically do
like a yoga class
while they electrocute you well that
sounds awful but hey much like beauty
getting ripped is pain
number five
we've heard his voice but just wait for
his physical transformation there's
clearly an added layer of pressure which
i will embrace mahershala ali joined the
mcu when he voiced blade at the end of
the film eternals and in 2021 he started
his training understanding just what
kind of work awaited him and that he did
cardio clean eating weightlifting and
specialized training for the role did
the trick
number six
she had a bit of a leg up when it came
to getting into shape the actress did
not hesitate in diving into the work i
took it upon myself uh and started
training what did all that training
involve well to start three thousand
crunches
yep you heard us three things oh the
number yeah no wonder she wasn't kidding
when she said the training for this was
uh very intense with her dad by her side
every step of the way steinfeld was
superhero ready in no time
number seven
how much training did he do i was
wondering when i would hit this point
and that that time is right now simulu
was working himself to that rough point
on the regular doing everything from the
marvel diet to exercising endlessly but
all of it would have been for nothing
had he not focused on the key to
unlocking all his potential stretching
his support team was stretching him out
five times a week for a whopping four
months to get him ready to nail all
those moves on set but liu knew just how
much prep he'd need to do understanding
that obviously learning the martial arts
is a big part of my training but the
other part of being a marvel superhero
is well looking like a superhero and it
seems like we can all agree that he
definitely looks like a superhero
number eight
she just can't quit with filming facing
all sorts of delays during the pandemic
brie larson had to keep up with her
training so she'd be ready to film
captain marvel too and she succeeded her
workouts were seriously intense we
grease joints here we don't warm up we
grease even if she had to work with her
trainer virtually larson made sure it
happened the actress gained her
unbelievable strength through some
hardcore bodyweight workouts which
sometimes included metal chains to make
the workout that much harder larson can
hold her entire body up for nearly a
full minute
what a marvel
number nine
he's thor how much more muscular can he
get seriously look at those biceps what
does hemsworth have to say about it well
it's more than just protein shakes
that's for sure there's the working out
there's the food and there's the sleep
when you approach health like that and
are concentrated in making sure you
respect each of those three things as
much as the other two you can quickly
find balance and from balance you gain
structure and a base on which you can
succeed the twice a day two hour
workouts five days a week with a dash of
meditation on the side made for the
perfect recipe for success
number 10
watch out mcu tayana paris is bringing
the heat no matter where she was the wan
division actress found a way to get her
workouts in meaning she was regularly
getting her sweat on in garages and
hallways hit workouts and strength
training gave her a solid core and
bodyweight exercises helped her to bulk
up if she had the chance to get some
training in she jumped for it wherever
whenever now that is commitment
number 11.
even with children's toys he trained
okay well he still worked with real bow
and arrows as well but his kids toy ones
did the trick when they were all stuck
in quarantine the pandemic was tough and
renner did let working out take a back
seat explaining i got i wouldn't say fat
but a little lazy i was like f that it
was sloth's life but when he did jump
back on to the workout training he did
two straight months to get into good
enough shape just to return to the stunt
gym number 12
from falcon to captain america the work
never stops
anthony mackey's daily routine is no
joke the first thing i do in the morning
is 100 push-ups that's before he even
has coffee then he casually warms up if
you can even call this a warm-up i run
four miles to the gym get in i'm already
warm from the jog 30 minutes of legs and
this lasted for a whole five months
closer to filming bumping up to twice a
day workouts the diet was oh so clean
focusing mainly on plant-based foods and
lean proteins oh and of course he never
forgot about that core every day you hit
abs for 20 minutes and that folks is how
you train like captain america number
13.
florence pew went to work but some
things did get in her way someone
attacked my hair
when i was doing some crunches while the
actress got fit for her roles she was
pretty clear on laying down how she felt
about physical transformations for jobs
discussing it with production early on
when i got the job i wanted to know what
the regime was that was a big deal for
me i didn't want to be part of something
where i was constantly checked on and
people making sure i was in the right
shape that's not for me pew did make
sure her body was ready to handle the
toll that filming a marvel project can
take building as much muscle and
strength as she could with her trainer
james shields
number 14
watch out this loki is ready to fight
all her sword drills were a major
benefit in training for when the time
came for her to actually perform the
battles on screen dimartino made sure to
jump on the work quickly we started
prepping really early i think it was
january 2020. first thing we did was get
into the stunt gym and start boxing
training sword drills just like working
out trying to get fit i just had a baby
so i had a lot of work to do
number 15.
when isn't he working out apparently
never but he does ramp up the intensity
of his workouts before filming making
sure the buckybarn's bulk he needs is
there to get his work started 10 minutes
of cardio followed by lifting the
heaviest weight he could get his hands
on
these actors push themselves to the
extreme but the results
absolutely worth it would you take on
any of these workouts